cocktail et easy ans rejoint les rangs
ils sont les nouveaux agents des polices
municipales d'elancourt et maurepas
nous disposons d'un certain nombre de
lieux de détente plus fréquentées sur
cette période tels que sur la commune de
maurepas le bassin de la courance la
coulée verte sur elle en cours ce sont
des exemples la patrouille est prévue de
10 heures à 18 heures avec une
possibilité de décaler jusqu'à 22 heures
donc il s'agit de deux agents donc un
agent de la commune de maurepas un agent
de la commune d'el en cours tous deux
cavaliers et volontaire sur cette action
les deux trotteurs français viennent
d'un centre équestre proche de gambe et
des chevaux non mes motifs facilitant
les patrouilles
on a une allure qui est un peu plus
rapide que de marcher à pied emmenait en
même temps suffisamment longue pour bien
observer et on est beaucoup plus aussi
que quelqu'un qui à pied ou sur un vélo
donc on a un point de vue beaucoup plus
générale on peut notamment regarder
par-dessus les clôtures voir l'arrière
des maisons prendre les petites sente
piétonne ce qui nous permet d'avoir un
autre angle de surveillance le
dispositif coûte 4300 euros par commune
un bilan sera fait à l'issue pour
évaluer cette brigade
le bruit des sabots s'entendra jusqu'au
18 août